di odio tanto bene da tutti ragazzi
venuti a questo video sono bravi
generosissimo tardi sul super meat boy
eravamo rimasti che ero arrivato al boss
finale di super meat boy e me ne ero
data a gambe nel senso che non l'avevo
battuto sì sì sì sì sì sì sì sì certo
che era data a gambe perché è
impossibile
e stato veramente una purga riuscirà a
trovare anche solo a batterlo non mi
ricordo visti gioco ragazzi perché è
passato un anno da quando giocato
l'ultima volta super meat boy però ci
posso provarlo stesso ok ok ok ok
perfetto ecco 55 di valori allora aveva
sentite io non l'avevo finito il super
ma c'è un motivo se non lavoro finito ok
quel problema che potrei passarci la mia
vita ok ok ma io c'ero arrivato ragazzi
prima non era qua il problema era più
avanti c'era un punto in cui non
riuscivano andare avanti più allora ha
lasciato perdere ha detto vabbè mi do a
lipica ok ok e fin qua ora gara è da
secoli non ci gioco da anni non mi
ricordo non so neanche come sto facendo
sta roba
infatti sono crepato come un idiota
ditemi voi ragazzi se devo dedicare un
[ __ ] episodio ma [ __ ] un
[ __ ] episodio solo per battere un
boss neanche per solo questo proviamoci
adesso ragazzi non lo smartphone sono
benedetto non sono neanche partito già
mica così vago come devo andare devo
andare a culo perché non sono anche
marmi indecente io non so veramente
cadere lì porca put cosa riti dai dai
dai dai dai su perfetto
io finiti tutti sono arrivati alla fine
del gioco e non ho fatto il vostro nome
il boss non l'ho fatto perché è
difficile non l'ho fatto perché è
difficile e allora che cazzo spari cammi
cosa spa riguarda se già arrivo quale un
miracolo ok ecco e muoio per forza però
che ho deciso di giocare a questo schifo
pixel erano dimenticati tutti nessuno me
lo faceva più notare perché è comodo
ok ok ok
e fin qui ci arrivo salto qui e fin qui
ci arrivo arrivo su questo cazzo di muro
continua a saltare sul muro mi salvo
vado qui perfetto no io mi rifiuto di
credere che ci siano persone che hanno
finito super mito è impossibile ok e
siamo arrivati qua per miracolo divino
ok adesso arrivo quale crepe sicuro
cazzo cazzo mi piace l'ho fatta non è
possibile
vai vai vai no ma perché cioè la mira di
mia nonna in calore allora allora sul
primo ci sono uscito perché non ci
riesco più cosa che problema c'è la
sorella quest'ultima parte non c'è mi
faccia solo incazzare ancora il problema
perché ho smesso madonna dare testate in
bocca che ha creato sul livello
impossibile ok ok ok
si no
cazzo cazzo cazzo cazzo
sorella putrefatta nei cimiteri
ok ora che non ci si si si oh oh oh cosa
c'è di quel che devo fare qua che cazzo
devo fare qua a dire oddio cos'è lo
avevo visto la lama che grossa quanto
piano perché non l'ho vista l'ho vista
bene bene bene dai dai dai dai su su su
su con la vita su una è giro è e cioè
bravissimo bravissimo bravissimo
problema serie tua sorella concime
complimenti complimenti bravo ok ok ok
oddio che ansia si cosa faccio cosa
faccio testo la mamma incesto la mamma
cosa fa
cosa non va più il tasto a destra non va
più il tasto a destra lo sto premendo
non va più che problemi hai dal
dall'ulcera gesù cristo gesù noi abbiamo
tutto il gioco che è cresciuto perché
ovviamente sono uscito ma non importa
perché tanto sono al punto di partenza
ho iniziato 40 minuti fa sono ancora
questioni super sua madre dai ragazzo un
carnet forza forza sono morto anna ma
dài dài delle ragazze che l'una di notte
gridando come una [ __ ] isterica e
saranno tutti svegli ma chi cazzo se ne
frega no
no perché ci ha messo 3,4 secondi a
riprendere i comandi perché non era un
pezzo non ci provavo si ok ok e stiamo
vivo qua e siamo di nuovo
ecco ecco e maemo emo e ma cosa cazzo
faccio della mia vita
ce l'avevo fatta l'avevo fatta dovevo
andare subito sciocco ho capito come si
fa se non ti ci tornerò mai più
nell'universo parallelo di di adventure
time ladra [ __ ] vacca laida ok dai
ma perché è bene è già fin qua il 90 per
cento delle volte non riesco perfetto ok
manca solo tutto il resto ma porca
[ __ ] non lo so
sì sì sì sì bravo bravo bravo bravo mi
piace mi piace
bravo ma che cazzo fa ma che cazzo fa ok
ok ok ok no no no no non ho problemi per
un device 9so dovevo gratta minato cazzo
sono ragazzi sono sul soffitto bene
la missiva ore qui a si muore qualche
bella notizia non sapevo la potevo star
lì tutta la vita la considerava una
vittoria ma niente mai nella vita
soccorro di qua a salgo su per questo
minchia di muro per la quarantesima
volta prova a passare in mezzo ma muoio
guardali che lo sapevo ma a morire se lo
sapevo come madonna chiuso schivato
oddio oddio cosa ho fatto
vabbè vabbè è tanto
oddio due sono cosi bastardo
no no no no aiuto aiuto io non ho mica
tso è cosa esce un bottone ho fatto non
è possibile non ci posso credere mai
nella vita c'è anni per che cosa fanno
estate uscirà uscite veloci sono riccia
che devo fare qualcos'altro mi girano le
palle ve lo dico che fate oddio è sono
morte bene finito che si ragazzi
complimenti bel gioco
no è super merda voi mi sta salvando
merda poi grazie merda voi deve uscire
con la tipa mentre merda poi morirà
schiacciato sotto le macerie che dio
merda voi merda boy morti tutti ma
chissenefrega tanto si scopa
oddio no vabbè c'è anche un acoustic
version
e gratificata no vabbè che stile quindi
e quindi si trovano ancora cos'è sta
roba
super meat boy è finito così c'è un
finale aperto nel senso che è stata
stuprata la tizia quindi quindi c'è un
esempio
oddio lo scoiattolo a capirlo ciao zio
come stai sopravvissuto a una bomba
atomica non si sa come va bene così
chiudo qui questo cazzo di videogame non
ne voglio più sapere nella vita
basta tutti ragazzi spero che video vi
sia piaciuto vi ringrazio per avermi
chiesto così tante di fare il finale
visto che non avevo fatto vi ringrazio
di volermi così bene anch'io che ne
voglio quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto un mi piace per il finale
perché porta a [ __ ] ce l'abbiamo
fatta
spero che vi siate certe cose se avete
bisogno di duemila pagine di facebook
comuni video totale estinzione se non
server si distrae mai ci vediamo non
fosse un viso della ragazza